je suis le dr tardy commencé par me dire
comment vous appelez et au milan nom de
code le livre les homes il en existe pas
si ma couverture
c'était un bon bitouah quoi je crois
vraiment que c'est un espion justement
je retrouve camionnette de fleuriste
aucune soit il va se faire enlever soit
la serbie avait fuit pas mon amour
pendant le mec se prend pour james bond
vous aviez raison louise a été enlevé
c'est là que ça fait c'est parce que
vous croyez je vous ai ajouté des
amphétamines pour stimuler cheminot je
suis vraiment concentré vous désirez
bonne foi avec ce que tu m'a injecté
dans le derche âgées le cully dans sa
techno et à prendre deux trois mots pour
te défendre ce coup le coût du lion les
voix ne pousse que les voyous et les
bois
c'est beau à eau
comment tu t'es fracassé
vous n'êtes pas un espion agde mirren
jamais se fier aux apparences
arrêté à la fin règle numéro 2 ferme ta
bouche tu auras chaude en vous vous êtes
sûr de boules je suis déjà fait en 1 2
l'indochine c'était les années 60 pour
n'étaient même pas nés qu'est ce que ton
se discute du crabe soit sorti de
l'asile ou quoi donc tant qu'on ne se
trompe pas
oh mais vous n'êtes jamais on est deux
on ne parlait
[Musique]